pas du tout
[Musique]
m
en fait
[Musique]
figaro live bienvenus nous sommes en
direct ce mercredi matin on va suivre
les obsèques de jean pierre pernaut qui
se déroule en ce moment comme vous
pouvez le voir à la basilique
sainte-clotilde dans le 7e
arrondissement je suis avec gilles
boussingault journalistes aux tv mag
bonjour bonjour j on va parler un peu de
la personnalité du père pernaut des
invités qui arrivent petit à petit une
cérémonie pour une pour un grand nom de
la télévision français absolument on
peut le voir d'ailleurs sur les images
c'est presqu'une enterrement d'une star
d'ailleurs jean pierre pernaut même
s'ils ne se définissait pas comme ça
c'était comme une star de la télévision
c'était quelque chose qu'il avait réussi
à bâtir petit à petit non pas parce
qu'il était présentateur du jt mais
simplement parce qu'il aimait les gens
qu'il était quelqu'un de simple qui
n'avait jamais jamais refusé une
autographe ou ou un contact avec les
gens il les aimait profondément il avait
bâti comme ça sauf une pluie de ces
trente années de carrière un record
d'ailleurs dans son métier il avait pâti
comme ça sans sa personnalité son aura
la journaliste présentateur des jt est
proche les gens je pense que aujourd'hui
on le voit les gens lui rendent hommage
en étant aussi nombreux dans ses amis
certainement que les laits comment les
légendes du grand public à l'extérieur
de la
wii on a beaucoup de commentaires dans
le cas du figaro qui de le de gens qui
doit apporter leur leurs condoléances
valent pas eu par exemple qui nous dit
condoléances à la famille et aux amis on
a eu beaucoup de personnalité présente
effectivement que michel drucker
hannecart coudray tous ses anciens
collègues visant aussi et j'ai pu y sont
présentes tf1 voilà beaucoup de beaucoup
de personnes connues qui sont présents
pour montrer à quel point ces
personnages et était adoré exactement le
cas aussi la présence de martin bouygues
qu'on a pu voir
apparemment plusieurs miss france
également sont attendus et puisqu'on se
rappelle quand même c'était le dernier
absolument absolument
tf1 présente depuis longtemps les séries
miss france mais jean pierre était un
incontournable de la maison je veux dire
depuis plus de 30 ans qui présentait le
jt tout le monde le connaissait il était
apprécié de tous c'est quelqu'un qui qui
a toujours été
très très simple qui n'a qui n'a jamais
été
la star du du jt s'était il l'a fait
mais c'était pas lui je veux dire
c'était il était c'était quelqu'un de
très simple encore une fois comme je le
disais il était apprécié pour sa de tout
le monde tout le monde est ce qu'il a vu
nu une recette une idée lui c'était les
régions s'étaient servir de paris
absolument lui quand il a pris le jt
bahia plus un peu plus de 30 ans
maintenant son idée de base était de
sortir de ce parisianisme d'ailleurs ils
m'ont le cours d'une interview que j'ai
eu la chance de faire dans son bureau il
m'avait raconté qu'à l'époque le
journalisme tourner un peu autour d'eux
le du pont de l'alma et qu'il fallait
sortir de ça et donc il a mis en place
petit à petit un réseau de
correspondants dans toute la france en
s'appuyant sur les grands titres de
presse quotidienne régionale qui a été
le réseau numéro 1 en france et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'ils ont une
vingtaine de bureaux qui couvre un
maillage incroyable en france et qui il
en a fait finalement le premier journal
des régions pourtant il diffusait son
journal depuis paris mais on aurait pu
croire france 3 était la chaîne des
régions en fait jean pierre pernaut
avait réussi à transformer son journal
télévisé en journal des régions et s'est
intéressé au quotidien des français aux
métiers oubliés enfin auxerre il a lancé
d'ailleurs plusieurs opérations
spéciales au cours de sa carrière sur
les marchés sont les plus beaux les plus
belles activités fin voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui s'intéressait à sa ville
et à sa vie et à la france avant tout
oui il n'y avait pas que l'international
ou non ou ou où la politique c'était
raconter d dès 10h de vos régions
quelques pas exactement il s'intéressait
à la france à son pays lui même
d'ailleurs avec une grande une passion
pour pour sa région pour amiens
d'ailleurs c'est que quelque part en
discutant avec lui que j'ai découvert
les hortillonnages d'amiens
il aimait beaucoup sa région et puis
c'était quelqu'un qui nature était
curieux il s'était pris de passion pour
le théâtre il ya quelques années théâtre
qu'il avait fait avec avec son épouse
nathalie marquay il s'intéressait aussi
à la voiture à la vitesse sans fils a
été pilote donc j'avais je l'avais aussi
rencontré sur circuit de montlhéry où il
avait une formule 1 avec son fils c'est
quelqu'un qui s'intéressait à tout et
qui ne jugea personnes il y avait une
grande qualité humaine il est comme j
étais bien qu'ils étaient malgré un
succès qui quand même trente ans plus de
30 ans au jt c'est bien qu'ils étaient
restés très humble dans très simple
absolument tout le monde pouvait lui
parler tout le monde pouvait l'approcher
il restait très sympathique très simple
souriant et pourtant il a il a fait
jusqu'à à la grande époque jusqu'à 7
millions de téléspectateurs au jt il
était parti devant 200 journaux
télévisés or la chine
comment être à 13 heures donc c'est
vraiment il a présenté le plus grand
journal d'élise d'europe donc c'est
quelqu'un qui aurait pu se prendre la
tête se dire je suis là ça pas du tout
il est resté très proche des gens et
c'est d'ailleurs cette relation
proximité qu'il avait qui faisait que il
parvenait à obtenir des sujets pour son
jt sur des métiers oubliés sur les
activités ce qui n'empêchait pas par
ailleurs de dire ce qu'il pensait quand
il en avait envie parce que jean-pierre
sous ses commandes hors très gentil
n'avait pas non plus la langue dans sa
poche c'était quelqu'un qui disait ce
qu'il pensait tout simplement oui lui
parle de coup de gueule vendée gilet
jaune après le monde jouit la
circulation à paris tout ça parce qu'ils
disaient ce qu'ils voyaient en fait il
avait cette espèce de bon sens français
qu'on retrouve dans les rites dans nos
régions françaises voilà parce que lui
était l'anti parisianisme envoyée il
était l'anti
prise de tête qui vit dans son
microcosme parisien simplement on à nina
almac lui dit adorable ce grand monsieur
pernaut lui aimait les gens et cela se
sent t on a parlé aussi cette proximité
qu'il a réussi à créer avec les régions
et vers les gens absolument et
d'ailleurs à ce titre comment il avait
réussi à créer un tel maillage et une
telle affection avec les téléspectateurs
eux et afin recevait chaque jour des
centaines de lettres au jean pierre ou
des colis les gens lui envoyait du
saucisson une tarte et receveurs nt
demande en mariage donc le service
courrier avec tf1 était occupée grâce
allait effectivement la romaine loir
nicolas sarkozy danser sur ces images
alors ta caméra dézoomer il était sur la
gauche de ses emails nicolas sarkozy à
un ancien président qui vient c'est vrai
que ça montre aussi à quel point ces se
présentèrent était très important
absolument il était vraiment reconnue de
tous il a fait l'unanimité
de ses confrères par sa gentillesse son
sourire encore une fois son
accessibilité c'était pas la star du jt
parisien voilà c'est quelqu'un qui
voulait rester proche des gens il a
aussi permis à tf1 de s'imposer
d'imposer son jt quand il prend les
cantons qui prend les commandes du jt le
jt de tf1 est derrière seul celui de
france 2 d'antenne 2 mai mais ensuite le
jt de tf1 va devenir le premier de
france absolument il a été à bonne école
parce que il a commencé donc en 75 comme
rédacteur en chef et à la présentation
du journal du soir et il l'a fait quand
même deux années l'équipe mourousi donc
ça c'est pas rien il mourousi qui était
quand même un présentateur phare aussi
comment là elle a beaucoup aidé la
beaucoup entraîné et il a fait une année
seuls ou jt et en 87 c'est le départ
plus de trente années de règne sans
partage sur les audiences j'entends
et donc 43 ans à tf1 il a commencé
d'ailleurs pour être précis le 6 janvier
75 voilà donc c'est un star record
effectivement c'est si vous habitez
impressionnante alors qu'on vient de
voir rentrer brigitte macro nicolas
sarkozy et carla bruni sarkozy qui fait
qu'ils sont tous les trois à rentrer
dans ce match et qu'on n'aura pas les
images des obsèques puisque c'est ça se
passe dans l'intimité mais on a des gens
disent qu'ils sont sur place et qui
pourront raconter ce qu'ils ont vu bien
évidemment c'est ce genre de d'obsèques
république c'est quelque chose de de
commun pas tant que ça alors on ne sait
pas encore ce qu'il en sera pour pour
d'autres grandes vedettes de la
télévision jantes mais comme journaliste
mais c'est passé pas tan tan tan
tan courant que ça en fait on en voit
bien grâce à cette cérémonie que jean
pierre a fait l'unanimité autour de lui
encore une fois qu'il était apprécié de
tous des politiques comme d'aider
certains sportifs ou des gens de la
société civile parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui ne jugent à personne voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui savait et qu'il
savait rester aussi il se lançait pas
dans la politique il ne faisait pas de
rester neutre toujours qui aimait son
métier en tout on a vu par exemple
michel drucker très très très touché
c'était il était à lyon de route depuis
des années ils se connaissaient très
très bien
michel drucker a d'ailleurs est un
personnage qui ressemble à pas
jean-pierre c'est quelqu'un qui essaye d
mis tout le monde qui essaie de bien
vouloir s'entendre avec tout le monde
parce que ce sont des gens qui aiment
les hommes les gens justement donc
effectivement pour michel drucker ils
ont à peu près le même âge il me semble
c'est un c'est un choc oui est-ce que
vous dire que jean pierre pernaut a été
assez visionnaire d'ordre dans sa façon
de voir le journalisme pour avoir une
telle longévité pour pour s'intéresser
autant aux organes comme je le disais
tout à l'heure jean pierre a tout de
suite compris que ce qui intéressait
les français en dehors de la grande
messe du 20 heures qui aurait capitulé
l'information internationale et les
grands les grands événements politiques
il fallait parler aux gens de ce qu'ils
connaissent de ce qu'ils aiment et donc
de leur quotidien ça il l'a vu tout de
suite et quand il a voulu mettre ça en
place la direction à l'époque le liban
vas-y tu vas carte blanche fait le donc
ça a été un gros travail et finalement
il est arrivé à construire comme en une
un journal qui l'a acheminée au fil des
années pour en faire une machine qui
roulaient les machines qui était bien
huilée qui faisait qui rassemblait le
maximum de téléspectateurs
et quand marie sophie lacarrau
d'ailleurs a pris sa succession elle a
compris qu'il fallait pas à 2 feront
changer la machine que jean-pierre la
mise en place elle avait discuté avec
lui d'ailleurs il l'avait reçue
s'étaient parlé elle avait compris que
il fallait se savait rien de faire voler
en éclats la quelque chose qui était
aussi apprécié les téléspectateurs qui
mesure qui marche 12 ans exactement elle
a préféré c'était très intelligent de sa
part d'ailleurs mettre en place des
choses par petites touches et finalement
il y à porter elle-même sa personnalité
c'était difficile de succéder une
personnalité comme jean-pierre la marie
sophie l'a très bien compris donc elle
n'a rien voulu révolutionner
effectivement
c'est son il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui arrêtent qui regardait ce jt c'est
au même aujourd'hui le jt de tf1 est
plus populaire que celui de france 2 ah
oui oui largement oui d'ailleurs il y
avait une petite comment il était temps
le jeune gendarme jean pierre il est
tellement populaire et surtout la
formule qu'il avait mise en place était
tellement populaire que quand il
discutait avec avec jacques legros qui
le remplaçait pour les commandes en tant
que joker le petit jeu entre eux c'était
de savoir à qui ferait la meilleure
audience parce que quand jean pierre est
en vacances il était en contact
directement avec ge avec jacky la paix
en disant ah mais j'ai fait plus
d'audience que toi cette fois ci et puis
comme jean-pierre revenait il est encore
plus d'audience que jacques était leur
petit jeu entre eux c'était amusant
jean-pierre au delà de sa personnalité
d'homme apprécié gentil avait réussi à
mettre effectivement en place une
formule d'agiter retrouve nulle part
ailleurs il faut bien le dire qui marche
est effectivement
aussi d'aider des opérations qui a lancé
sos villages sur les sur les marchés sur
les marchés absolument et ces choses qui
ont permis de revitaliser
les territoires entre guillemets
français absolument c'est quelque chose
qu'il n'a jamais voulu abandonner parce
qu'il était conscient justement que ceux
qui l'écoutaient ceux chez lesquels ils
entraient avec le prisme de la caméra
était précisément des comment des gens
qui vivaient sur tout le territoire
français et pas seulement des parisiens
donc il a voulu s'intéresser à leur
priorité à leur quotidien en les mettant
en lumière et en mettant et en essayant
sauver des personnes si vous voulez
qu'ils ne s'étaient jamais dans la
lumière qui se battait au quotidien pour
sauvegarder un héritage une tradition
jean-pierre il était très attaché à ça
et c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
l'unanimité des téléspectateurs on a vu
de nombreuses personnes présentes tout
autour on ad'ailleurs d'aidé aux mal
pire est qu'ils me disent ce n'est qu'un
adieu jean pierre soisson à jamais dans
nos coeurs et nos pensées grand merci
pour ta simplicité et ton très grand
coeur vous le disiez vous l'aviez
rencontré jeux jean-pierre pernaut que
j'ai repris à bas
prix qu'est ce qui vous a le plus marqué
la première fois que vous l'avez
rencontrée c'est sa simplicité en fait
il m'a parlé juste moi j'étais je
commence je commençais j'étais quand
même assez impressionné de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui avait déjà plusieurs
années de journalisme d'ailleurs lui qui
était connue de tous et il avait aussi
les avait un grand bureau à tf1 je me
souviens c'est sa simplicité
et la gentillesse avec laquelle il m'a
parlé en fait j'aurais pu croire qu'on
se connaissait depuis des années et à
chaque fois je les revues à chaque fois
c'était le même sourire là même la même
gentillesse le même accueil c'est
quelqu'un qui me parler en toute
simplicité qui disait ce qu'il pensait
mais qui n'était pas qu'ils se la jouer
par vedette mois alors qu'on vient de
voir s'il y en a qui vivent qui vient de
rentrer qui a répondu aux questions de
tf1 tf1 charismatique spéciale on
imagine pour cette cérémonie c'est ça
aussi qui est fort avec jean pierre
pernaut c'est qu'on voit qu'il a été
mais de toutes les générations on
aperçoit qu on a vu michel drucker et on
a du ciel absolument c'est ce que jean
pierre aimait à dire c'est que ce n'est
pas le journal seulement des mamies et
les papys comment employer un terme
actuel mais
il était il touchait toutes les
générations toutes les générations de 7
à 77 ans et même jean pierre pernaut
parce qu'il avait su s'intéresser au
quotidien encore une fois des français
et quand il a quitté le jt d'ailleurs il
avait monté tout un tout un site web
où il continuait à parler des régions et
sur lequel il faisait réagir les gens
précisément c'était ça qui l'intéressait
l'interactivité avec son public et donc
tous aimaient pouvoir parler avec lui
parce que les gens se sentait proche de
lui il n'est pas en fait c'est cette
cette barrière delà de la télévision il
était dans le salon des français pour
leur parler un peu comme un ami parle
un autre en lisant bah voilà en ardèche
on est encore en train soudan le sud est
dia telle chose tel métier les gens on
apprenait sur leur propre pays grâce à
lui et donc c'est cette simplicité cette
familiarité au bon sens du terme qui
fait que ça touchait toutes les
générations il a aussi fait des
événements qu'on l'arrêté le jt n'a pas
réussi à complètement coupée avec les
telle aide l'adhésion c'était aussi un
beau travail non absolument
il n'a t elle et pourtant il a eu des
petits problèmes de santé ces défauts
opéré du genou il a eu des choses qui
l'ont obligé de se tenir éloignés de
l'écran mais quand et leur revenait
c'est la chose première chose qui
voulait faire c'était revenir à
l'antenne revenir avec son public et
présenter le journal c'était quelque
chose qu'il adorait c'est sa passion sa
grande passion au delà d'autres passions
qu'il avait comme la pêche par exemple
il importe de mobiles que vous aidez la
course automobile exactement le théâtre
puisqu'il a quand même vite avec son
épouse nathalie
il commet il y avait son métier il était
passionné par son métier simplement et
puis et puis on lisait tout à l'heure
c'est une voisine l'histoire avec les
avec les bêtes les miss france qui c'est
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on devient un
personnage aussi populaire oui bah oui
parce que la miss après miss france est
très suivi comment sur tf1 d'ailleurs
sur le web du tv magazine c'est quelque
chose qui fait beaucoup réagir les
comment les internautes
donc effectivement en présentant une
telle cérémonie il avait su attirer
d'autres d'autres personnalités d'autres
personnes d'autres types de public qui
ne regardaient pas forcément son jt donc
il avait prouvé que c'est quelqu'un qui
était multicartes qui n'était pas
simplement dédié un type de journalisme
mais qui pouvait tout faire il était ces
tests et universaliste jean-pierre
c'était quelqu'un de s'intéresser à tous
et à la touche à tout j'ai eu après si
on touche à tout de génie parce qu'en
fait ils osaient toujours bien et avec
bienveillance à utiliser quelque chose
avec passion donc ça c'est ce que les
gens ont ressenti chez lui il ya cédric
qui fait un commentaire qu'il va dans ce
sens là jean ferrat nous va beaucoup me
manquer c'était le meilleur journaliste
qui était d'une simplicité incroyable
françoise qui dit fuir son âme est de
tout coeur avec avec la famille on l'a
vu une grande famille qui est présente
aujourd'hui à la basilique
sainte-clotilde dans le dans le 7e
arrondissement une cérémonie qui est qu
elle qui a lieu du coup bon là c'est la
partie publique mais à prix sera inhumé
dans l'intimité oui absolument
d'ailleurs nous nous confrères du
parisien on va arriver que apparemment
seuls les journalistes de tf1 qui en
avait fait la demande je pouvais
participer aux obsèques les journalistes
des autres médias visiblement n'étant
pas n'étant pas invités nous avons la
chance d'avoir été invités nous avons
deux journalistes qui sait qu'ils ont
présent puisque
on peut vous montrer jean pierre pernaut
et nathalie marquay pernaut avait fait
un plateau et ça ça de décembre il était
venu sur le plateau du bost et les
émissions du tv magazine pour justement
parler de la maladie de pour parler de
la maladie de jean pierre pernaut
absolument ça pour ça jean pierre s'en
est jamais cachée a toujours voulu être
franc et transparent avec son public
parce qu'ils savaient que les gens
suivent l île savez les gens l'aimaient
et donc plutôt que de révéler quelque
chose à la dernière minute préféré
l'annoncé par ce que il considérait que
son société les spectateurs les
téléspectateurs
étaient comme des amis auxquels ils
veillent préféré dire la vérité leur
parler franchement faut que de mentir
tous les tenants ce n'est pas dans sa
nature de mentir il voulait dire les
choses franchement quand il avait besoin
de quelque chose il n'y avait pas sa
langue dans sa poche il
convient qu'il ya qui arrive en ce
moment on va peut-être vous laisser
vivre ces images sans commentaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon coco
oui
[Musique]
donc on est en train de voir
effectivement c'est fake empire qui se
met en place pour sortir
pour sortir les cercueils vous êtes
encore nombreux à commenter lui next
misty une figure incroyable du jt de 13
heures il va beaucoup nous manquer
cédric je l'adoré c'est vraiment une
grande perte points de vente français je
suis trop triste une pensée pour sa
famille sylvia j'avais tellement être au
moment du trésor notamment formidable
vous sentiez que jp fait une belle âme
soit en paix condoléances à la famille
effectivement ce il avait réussi à
recréer de 13h à peut-être toujours été
une un grand rendez-vous mais il a
réussi à créer un vrai rendez vous à
tous traiteur absolument jean pierre a
expliqué que lui c'était un de ces
termes qu'il aimait bien il aimait la
france des sabots des forgerons en fait
et il avait compris si vous voulez qu
avec les
décennies qui passe le mode de vie des
français le changer et que donc
auparavant les gens qui déjeunaient pas
chez eux mais qu'ils étaient qui
déjeuner à la cantine ou l usine en
milieu
rural avec l'augmentation du chômage les
actifs rentrait de plus en plus souvent
déjeuner chez eux et donc les femmes
travailler de plus en plus et donc avec
un accès aussi plus grand de la part des
jeunes à la télévision il s'était ouvert
à 13 heures il s'était ouvert une grande
audience et donc ils avaient intéresser
les gens à 7 à cette france rurale
traditionnelle qu'il aimait et qu'il a
tissés qu'il a contribué à mettre en
avant par l'amba des décennies pendant
plus de trois décennies il aimait il
aimait cette france-là absolument sûrs à
bâle 1988 son premier jt donc ça date
une vraie longévité alors qu'on voit sur
ces images sa femme nathalie marquay
pernaut
c'est miss france ancienne miss france
aussi
un commune était utilisé qu'il est vous
le disais qu'il est qu'il a initiée au
théâtre absolument c'était une pièce de
terre d'ailleurs jean pierre etaix tir
très très fier de ça et c'est un couple
d'ailleurs qui était profondément
attaché ils s'aimaient beaucoup on
déplore et on ait du coeur avec avec son
épouse nathalie marquay pour la perte de
2 2 jean pierre mais oui c'était
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse et le théâtre
avait été pour lui une nouvelle une
nouvelle direction dans laquelle
s'embarquer qui n'avait rien à voir avec
le journalisme qui n'avaient rien à voir
non plus que ses préoccupations
quotidiennes sur la france comment des
régions est et sa salle ç'avait été un
nouvel aspect qu'il avait beaucoup
beaucoup intéressé alors on va voir le
cercueil qui est qui qui rentre dans
l'église
[Applaudissements]
voilà ma dernier hommage
les proches qui est sur place
qui est autour de lui
parce que
avec un peu de vent
oui oui puisqu'en gagnante initiateurs
de sécurité quelques mises en place
à personne
oui effectivement réer et on parlait
justement de c2c de ses nombreuses
personnalités
qui sont présentes alors je vais
reprendre à nice qui nous dit qu'ils
qu'il repose en paix je crois que j'ai
vu une note aux commentaires de qui
courent et qui nous dit condoléances
effectivement la la cérémonie va se
dérouler les portes de la deûle à 85
qu'il pense vont se fermer lac et ça
sera ça on sera un peu fini de la partie
publique on les reverra après ressortir
en fait absolument absolument
c'est ça qui est bien aussi c'est que
jean pierre était quelqu'un de très
publique il était aimé de tous les
français et je pense que les français
vont comprennent ce type d'événement
malheureusement nécessite aussi une
certaine intimité qui permet une phase
de recueillement qui permet voilà de
communier
à la mémoire du défunt on voit
d'ailleurs ces images il ya 2 2 images
de grands portraits de lui un portrait
qu'il va semble bien aux priorités et un
autre dans lequel il lève la main de
l'autre côté avec un grand sourire ça
c'est l'image de jean-pierre ça c'est
quelqu'un de souriant il fait signe aux
gens qui leur répond qui est présent qui
est là et c'est pour ça qu effectivement
et le il va beaucoup manquer aux
téléspectateurs parce que il avait cette
présence chaleureuse même quand il était
plus l'antenne d'ailleurs on savait
qu'il était là il est encore active sur
le web et voilà il sera plus désormais
dans l'est dans les foyers français mais
les gens continueront à en penser à lui
aurait peut-être me permettent
d'ailleurs de citer ce petit cette
petite poésie très rapide je crois que
c'est philippe prudhomme qui dit c'est
en famille autour de la table sur les
sièges plus écarter que ça fait là du
véritable je pense que dans les foyers
français aujourd'hui ça va se passer
comme ça malheureusement mais quand on
n'oubliera pas la mémoire de jean pierre
effectivement c'est une vraie c'est une
vraie personnalité ont le cul vous le
disiez justement sur ce site et c'est
quelqu'un que tu es très chaleureux ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui était fin
ils en ont pas du tout est vraiment
comme ça absolument c'était quelqu'un
qui était vraiment comme ça qui était
sincère et c'est ça je crois qu'il ya le
plus marqué téléspectateurs c'est cette
sincérité ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
était fin chez lui il aimait
profondément ce qu'il faisait d'ailleurs
il le disait il avait la confiance de
ses patrons il a vu d'ailleurs la
naissance de tf1 elin d'elia et lui ont
vraiment participé à cette année sans
cette chaîne il avait la confiance de
ses patrons il était vraiment
très aimé de tous et voilà il me disait
chaque matin il arrivait avec un immense
bonheur au bureau voilà c'est quelque
chose dont il s'est passé on l'a quand
même s'il a commencé en 88 87 87 6 c'est
que c'est quand même quelque chose une
longévité comme apprendre promoteur
c'est du jamais vu ben c'est du jamais
vu ces records on à michel drucker
évidemment mais qui n'est pas qu'ils
commençaient aussi dans le journalisme a
d'ailleurs mais qui aujourd'hui n'est
plus n'est pas présent terre de jt oui
c'est assez rare à la télévision une
telle ou telle longévité parce que il
avait réussi à athis et ce maillage
téléspectateurs unique en europe
unique en europe il intéressait tout le
monde mais c'est ça parce que alors je
crois que j'avais je vais essayer de
retrouver les chiffres que j'avais ici
mais son journal est le premier d'europe
finalement c'est pas quelque chose qui
existe dans les autres pays non c'est
pas quelque chose qui dans les autres
pays d'ailleurs je crois que la france
d'une manière générale avec ses jt de 20
heures elle puis on regarde le plus de
gîte et en europe finalement ici ont
toujours premier en audience mais jean
pierre avait avait aussi une incroyable
expérience qui faisait de lui comment
qu'il mettait à l'aise partout il avait
quand même il avait connu trois
présidents de chaînes en trente ans ils
avaient connu quatre ou cinq directeur
de l'info il avait fait les couvrir
l'élection si l'élection de président de
la république il avait rencontré trois
papes enfin voilà ce n'est pas quelqu'un
on l'imposé à qui on a imposé facilement
mais il avait justement grâce à ça
malgré tout toujours conservé cette
simplicité qui ce qui fait je pense la
marque de fabrique d'un grand homme pas
très bien alors je viens de lire les
quelques derniers commentaires sophie
rizon toutes mes pensées à sa famille
marie france est une grande perte nous a
accompagnés durant des années dans notre
quotidien par terminèrent de la
télévision au trésor vous me manquerez
daniel repose en paix jean-pierre
analyse condoléances à tous ses proches
ouais on le voit encore une fois de
nombreux de nombreux nombreux
commentaires qui viennent saluer sa
mémoire vous est d'ailleurs très
nombreux à nous suivre actuellement
merci beaucoup gilles avoir été présent
avec double mais pour pour décrypter un
peu tout ça pour voilà pour faire vivre
la mémoire de jean pierre pernaut encore
là les obsèques vont se dérouler puis
ensuite des gens pour ce fonds vont
sortir après sera inhumé ce sera une
inhumation dans l'intimité puisque là il
veut quand même resté ce qu'on peut
complètement comprendre merci à vous en
tout cas de nous avoir suivi sur le
figaro d'avoir été très nombreux à nous
suivre pour ceux qui me suivent sur
youtube merci aussi n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour vous suivre d'autres live
du figaro et moi je vous dis à bientôt
sur figaro live